multiple summits we've seen that before
but president talking about this
possible summit on June 12th and if it
stays talking to Reuters on Air Force
One
I'd like to see see it done in one
meeting but oftentimes that's not the
way the deal works that's a very good
chance there's a very good chance that
it won't be done in one meeting or two
meetings or three meetings but it'll get
done at some point I look forward to
seeing the letter and I look forward to
June 12th where hopefully we can make
progress I'd like to see a total
denuclearization and as quick a period
of time as practicable you're talking
about machinery you're talking about
things that can necessarily happen
immediately but they can happen in as
rapid a fashion as they can happen
that's what I want to happen let's bring
in our panel start there Jonathan Swan
national political reporter for Axios
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and Charles Lane opinion
writer for The Washington Post so a
sense there's a kind of a setting of
expectations here of what could be a
first in the series that they don't
think that they're going to get it all
in one I talked to a senior White House
official yesterday about this and they
said that they're still you know hoping
that it's June 12th but there is still
an some uncertainty they're working
through details with North Korea
it could be pushed out by a few days and
of course who knows it's Kim jong-un
something could happen between now and
then that blows the whole thing up so
significant that this top guys coming
with very significant the Oval are very
significant and and and they are working
under the assumption that this is going
to happen the president wants it to
happen and even the skeptics on his team
like John Bolton the national security
adviser know that the President sees a
path here and and they're not fighting
the decision it obviously doesn't matter
that the date of June 12th it matters
what they get out of it and if they get
out of it right there's this pattern in
history where you have a really long
lead-up to a meeting you work out you
negotiate what exactly will be discussed
and then you hope for the best that will
happen at a meeting one gets the sense
here and it's possibly because we've had
such bad communication with this other
country going back that maybe just
meeting and getting things started right
away will be helpful even though I don't
think you can imagine that terribly much
will be accomplished so early that it
will take further meetings and more
hashing out
and we did here before Trump canceled
the meeting that North Korea had kind of
proposed similar things along the lines
of what they proposed in the past where
they give a big bundle of money in
exchange for promising to do something I
don't think that's gonna really satisfy
the US negotiators this timer and he
says will get up off the table meantime
the Russians are making a move to North
Korea he sends his warmest regards and
best wishes and the big endeavors that
have been initiated on the Korean
Peninsula with your participation the
situation on the Korean Peninsula is
changing according to the interests of
two countries I'm glad that Putin's
government is acting in opposition for
the domination of the United States we
are always ready to negotiate with the
Russian side peace stability and
prosperity on the Korean Peninsula and
in Southeast Asia in general or in our
interests so foreign minister Lavrov
warm and fuzzy with Kim jong-un clearly
sending a message that we're still
around we're still around we're still on
your border we want to know what's going
on
there's yes as these big events or
whatever that was on the Korean
Peninsula and it seems like it's getting
serious between you and Donald Trump
what I think it's very interesting about
that little meeting is it shows that Kim
jong-un has somehow managed to put
himself it's almost like he's courting
you know he's sort of the most eligible
bachelor for whatever in in in Northeast
Asia everybody's kind of coming to him
to see what he wants and what we can do
to make you happy and trying to get
influence with him and I think that's a
very strong position for him to be and
the United States has quite openly said
if you do business with us if you give
us what we want we are prepared to
guarantee your safety make you rich I
think the president even said make you
happy and that is a very sweet offer
that probably alarms the Russians and
the Chinese a little bit at the idea
that maybe the United States my gosh
will turn out to be the most influential
power right here in Northeast Asia over
time and they're moving to check that in
the meantime we are still checking the
Russia probe on a lot of different
fronts the president tweeting today
a number of tweets but this one not that
it matters but I never fired James Comey
because of Russia the corrupt mainstream
media loves to keep pushing that
narrative but they know it is not true
that prompted a lot of looking into
sound bites like this one from NBC
regardless of recommendation I was going
to fire call me knowing there was no
good time to do it and in fact when I
decided to just do it I said to myself I
said you know this Russia thing with
Trump and Russia is a made-up story it's
an excuse by the Democrats for having
lost an election that they should have
won so what was the deal with that tweet
storm Jonathan to figure out the White
House response no they're not really
talking much on this I actually did some
reporting today on other conversations
trucks been having privately been
pressuring Jeff Sessions for the best
part of a year over this they're just
not talking about it I don't think there
is a particularly good answer for that
you do the clip just a little bit longer
he talks a little bit more about how he
knows that firing Comey might actually
extend the Russia investigation but it
still must be done that clip is not that
difficult to understand he's saying that
he didn't like how James Comey was
privately assuring him that he was not
the target of Russia investigation while
publicly suggesting to the world that he
was that even though James Comey was
doing these J Edgar Hoover liked games
that were being played and that it might
cause him trouble on the Russia
investigation he still needed to fire
him because he was so bad at his job and
because he was bad for the American
people and I think particularly with
what we've learned about James Comey in
the year since that interview was given
which I think was just about a year ago
now we really should have a clear
understanding of what he was saying
there sure but they don't have you
talking for them and they don't have you
explaining it and and when the tweet
comes out it's not that clear so a lot
of times you have to read between them
not disagree with you that they could do
a much better job messaging what was
being said there by for instance just
putting out what that whole interview
with Lester Holt showed yeah meantime
Rudy Giuliani is going after trey gowdy
on what he said about the the informant
or the spy or whatever you want to call
take a listen I want to see the
documents which trey gowdy has never
seen which is outrageous and I'm not
gonna let my client testify the
president United States even if he wants
to without those documents being
produced if and when we find that this
was handled appropriately and and
there's some evidence on which they
could based it's phony investigation
well we haven't testified chuckle well
trey Gowdy did deliver at least in PR
terms a very heavy blow to the Trump
position in this by coming forward and
essentially blessing the Muller
investigation in this our sorry the FBI
investigation prior to Muller during the
election in this one respect and so
obviously they're pushing back very hard
I think if I may step back from what
what Giuliani is doing is kind of a
piece I thought with the Trump tweet
today they're kind of preparing the
ground on all sorts of different areas
for what might be the eventual
confrontation with Malloy the eventual
testimony and I think they're trying to
sort of lay down markers about like okay
here is our version of events here's our
version of the facts trey Gowdy ran
afoul of that so they push back I want
to point out that I wrote at the
Federalist that trey Gowdy actually
didn't even see all of the subpoenaed
documents that Congress is seeking to
understand more about the use of this
informant he also seemed confused about
whether it was a criminal probe he kept
saying well we don't use the term spy in
criminal probes but we should all know
now because James Comey testified about
this in March 2017 this wasn't a
criminal probe this was a
counterintelligence probe the use of
spies is common in a counterintelligence
probe what do you think that should be
what we do to political opponents in
during a campaign I think is really
something that people should really be
discussing and thinking through and
knowing so much more about whether they
are congressional investigators internal
watchdogs or people in the media but
when trey Gowdy has these meetings and
agreed that they didn't bring any
documents and they have a classified
debriefing and they explained what they
were doing and he comes out and says you
should be proud of what the FBI was
doing at the time and you would expect
that
how is that interpreted any other way
well I'm not entirely sure how to
explain what Trey Gaudi was saying
although he does have a history of being
very much a fan of the FBI but he also
conflated what he was saying in these
interviews about what President Trump
himself had said when James Comey first
presented to him information that about
the Russians which was of course after
the election he said he would like it
fully investigated and Gowdy said well
this means that it was of course okay to
run an informant against your campaign
and I don't think that and he's further
said that the American people support
the use of informants I don't think he
actually has a good grasp on what
American people think about running
informants on political game I want to
get to the other panel and trade and we
will only have a quick amount of time
but Jonathan also today the pardon of
Dinesh D'Souza the president indicates
that he is possibly considering a pardon
of Martha Stewart and Rob Blagojevich
his opponents some of them saying that
this is an indication mark Warner and
others saying the president's ad hoc use
of pardon power is concerning enough but
the possibility that he may also be
sending a message to witnesses in a
criminal investigation into his campaign
is extremely dangerous in the United
States of America no one is above the
law he's a pardon a pardon or is a
pardon a message I'm a reporter so I
need facts and this is the same thing as
before I can only report what I know for
a fact and I don't have any evidence
that Trump has said that to anyone
privately so for me to say yes that's
what he's thinking he would be pure
speculation out of thin air